i am curious as like the resident
american here oh yeah oh i'm the only
american pretty much the only only
american in in the office yeah right
apart from sydney um but sydney doesn't
count
i mean she likes ugly bastard hence none
of her opinions mean anything yeah i'm
like how did you feel when we actually
like rant about america and you're just
like off camera listening
that's true
we have been wrong about something yeah
you have been wrong but i'm just hanging
out whatever
things i mean yeah i mean we rag on
about our own countries just as much
yeah and then also americans will will
like rag on your kind of yeah yeah yeah
and whatnot we just it's interesting
though because like most my foreign
friends are usually american
and it's interesting hearing
non-americans talk about americans
that i know has there ever been a time
though where you were just like no
that's so wrong and i want to tell them
there are a few times i just forgot i
mean the one that sticks out is the
butter or the lard thing
you were saying that there's some place
that they put lard on popcorn i was like
yeah i've never heard of that
did we ever find out where that was or
is that a lot i i don't know no idea
it's not a lie because i saw it with my
own eyes
so it's like it's not a lie maybe it was
that cinema i don't know but i saw it
maybe it's probably yes yeah it's
probably not like a common thing because
i was like i mean melted butter is
definitely a common thing yeah yeah yeah
did you speak to many non-americans who
speak english before like non-americans
who speak english
in japan
like koreans i guess so yeah
is there a big difference between
americans and
non-americans the way you guys talk some
things you say and then i end up saying
it
like what
i don't know like the time that i almost
convinced you that the australian
currency no i didn't believe you i was
just you know being polite to your
friends
so at smash uh which is the convention
in sydney the animation
uh yeah so i got invited as a guest and
meline came with me yeah and uh and my
my friend from uni was there i invited
them and uh and i don't know how we got
into the conversation but my friend dead
ass almost convinced meleen that the
australian currency was called dollar-y
dues
before going i actually had an
australian friend here and she was like
oh uh australians lie a lot so watch out
and then i went up i think i told you i
was like my friend said australian smile
no no no no nonsense and then we told
you about the drop bears
i dropped there drop bears are like
there's a specific type of bear in
australia where uh
that they drop from the tree they drop
down and attack you so you should never
when you're in australia you should
never fall asleep under a tree because
drop bear could come down and uh attack
unfortunately that is a lie
i don't know it's absolutely real and
mainly believed me for a while yeah you
did you were like are they like an
actual species of bear
where where did the drop bear thing come
from oh [ __ ] it's been around since like
every every australian i swear i've met
abroad tells that story like on on my
first meeting i'm just like is this just
something the country has just agreed to
tell the entire rest of the world
from drop bears every year prove that
australia really exists prove that it's
not a lie yeah i i haven't seen it yet i
haven't seen it i've not been to
australia have you been to australia
yeah she's been have i yeah
she went on a flight and she landed
somewhere that was called australia but
that doesn't mean it exists you used to
be a big gamer back in the day right
maylene used to play maple story
yes
[Music]
did you not talk to like
people on on maple story oh yeah all
from all the countries my guild mother
was from australia
did she lie a lot
i don't think so she told me about a lot
of things but like to draw best what's
the guild what a what a guilt person who
starts the guilt would you would you put
yourself [ __ ] explained
i've never heard of it referred to as a
guild mother yes it just happens like
you know online
people in the games they date each other
and you can get married in a maple store
get crushed rings or whatever
and
yeah yeah
so did you not have like questions about
australia for her
not so much i wasn't because i remember
the first time i made an american friend
i asked them about so much [ __ ] about
about just like is it true that like
because you know in australia i did ask
a lot of questions because you know you
hear from you only hear so much from
media right to the point where like a
lot of it is like over-glorified and
sometimes just like a straight-up lie
yeah so like the first time i met my
american friend through youtube i just
asked them like a [ __ ] ton of questions
being like is this true is this i did
ask my brazilian friend about brazil
though
maple story do they really have big
butts no i asked them because there's
just one case a rumor or something that
kids are very violent when they get
angry at each other in games they like
kill each other and one of the cases
that i was like checking out was this 13
year old that like stole a ps4 or
something his friend and the friend got
angry went over to his house with the
magette and just smacked like cut him in
half and i was like oh is that true and
then his my friend thiago was like yeah
yeah that happens all the time so i'm
i'm not sure yeah
i didn't he didn't say yeah yeah he was
like yeah that happens a lot in in
ventrilo ventrilo
can can people confirm that in the
comments
brazilians is it true i don't know i was
like 13 14. does every brazilian kid
just own a machete
[Laughter]
but they're readily available so before
before before they learn how to read and
write they just get a machete
did they come on amazon or something i
don't know i was 13 and they told me
that and i was like oh something like
brazil is scary
i was always like the token british guy
and i went online to people yeah they
were just like yeah oh it's a brit oh
never met any british people in the
games really
maybe they played on different servers
maybe they did
yeah like how much growing up did you
know about the rest of the world because
like the stereotype is that americans
are nothing no nothing about the rest of
the world that's like the stereotype i'm
not saying it's true no about europeans
or australians or south america
you're vietnamese right yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah
i mean i got to travel to a lot of parts
of asia
i know about asia